the EU is the world leader in trade of
services in 2013 worldwide they yielded
873 billion euro surplus so it comes as
no surprise that it's deeply involved in
the current negotiations on a trade in
services agreement covering areas such
as passenger rights movement of workers
and e-commerce but the way negotiations
are taking place doesn't agree with all
mep s la people Daejeon South member
conorandalicia non-program Sucre and
acoma surely service disponible adios
amor transparent correlated 170 m eps
are watching closely the negotiations
between the European Commission and 23
other countries we need to get the
European interest and the reciprocity
applied that will be of utmost
importance other enemies have
reservations on what is being negotiated
we as grains will get involved in that
discussion and try to make sure that no
public services for example are touch
that on financial services we will still
be able to regulate and that always the
interest of the European citizens has
put forward a formal report will be
published in October